the state of arkansas is offering ten
thousand dollars in bitcoin for free to
anyone who qualifies and moves to
northern arkansas what yes the state of
arkansas is actually willing to give you
ten thousand dollars in bitcoin for free
here's the deal as we know governments
around the world are having to compete
for citizens because of the rise of
remote work digital currencies and all
sorts of digital economy businesses
people now have much more freedom to
move and decide where they want to live
not just because that's where their job
is but because they actually want to
live there and what we've seen is states
like california and new york suffer as
states like texas and florida have
benefited and what we've also seen is
that politicians in those states that
are actually benefiting have been a big
part of running marketing campaigns and
recruiting various citizens from around
the world to move to their geographic
locations well the state of arkansas
doesn't want to be left behind they've
created this bitcoin and bike program
they'll give you 10 000 in bitcoin for
free plus they'll also give you a bike
so you can enjoy the outdoors and the
biking trails all around northern
arkansas ultimately i think that this is
just the start local governments state
governments and even national
governments are all going to be
competing for citizens and seeing them
give out ten thousand dollars in bitcoin
for free is also something that i don't
think is going to be the outlier in the
future you're gonna see countries and
states and cities all paying whether
it's explicitly or implicitly maybe
they'll reduce your tax rates maybe
they'll actually hand you money like in
this case but whatever they're going to
do they're going to try as hard as they
can to get you to pick up and move and
if you've got a digital economy job and
you have the freedom of movement you're
going to start evaluating where you live
not just by where your job is but by
who's there what's the weather what are
the taxes and ultimately am i happier in
that place or not it's pretty cool to
see a place like arkansas a place that
most people wouldn't think would
participate in a program like this going
ahead and pioneering saying that anyone
in the world regardless of where you are
you can move to arkansas you can get
free bitcoin they've had all 50 states
go ahead and have citizens of those
states put forward applications they've
also had applications and interest from
over 100 countries around the world
there's not very many things that a
state can do to elicit that type of
positive response that type of interest
and potentially that type of economic
impact on a local community
kudos to arkansas but i think that
they're simply the first we will see
much much more of this going into the
future